wir hatten der letzten sitzung hatten
wir leibnitz behandelt seine theodizee
sie sehen hier ttc versuche über die
göttliche gerechtigkeit die freiheit des
menschen einen ursprung des bundes
und wir hatten nicht ganz den text zu
ende diskutieren können
wir hatten noch
ein paar stellen offengelassen und diese
stellen betrafen die konkrete auffassung
des bösen ziehen sich noch bei leibnitz
haben wir das sind drei maler wer von
ihnen kann doch mal kurz aufzählen was
für einmal bleibt es denkt ja
aber schon
genau schreibt immerhin mal um
metaphysik um
warum
brutale und mahnung physikum
das sind die themen mal an ich wurde
also mal korrigiert ich habe mir gesagt
maler maler ist aber falsch
ausgesprochen muss es kurz ton also mal
30 mal
und wir werden jetzt heute noch mal ein
bisschen sehen wie die gemeinsam
zusammenhängen mal um metaphysik um ist
die tatsache der endlichkeit der
geschöpfe der schöpfung die endlichkeit
der schöpfung die muss endlich sein weil
sonst wäre gott nicht nutzen würde er
sich
etwas im gleiches gegenüberstellen und
schaffen und dass es verleiht jetzt
nicht möglich
und aus dieser ähnlichkeit der schöpfung
folgen auf eine gewisse weise dass man
moral und das mal um physikum
damit ist aber nicht gesagt das betonte
auch leibnitz immer wieder dass diese
mal dieses moralische übel also zum
beispiel die sünde eine böse handlung
oder das physische wie eine krankheit
dass die notwendig aus dem mahnung
physiker metaphysik um folgen die folgen
nicht notwendigerweise draußen sind
immer noch kontingent aber sie sind eben
möglich sie werden dadurch möglich dass
wir endlich gewesen sind aber nicht
notwendig das ist eben ganz wichtig weil
sonst würde es nicht nur zur freiheit
stehen
ob wir was gutes oder böses tun dass wir
jetzt gerade behaupten und auch sichern
wenn man hier noch mal den titel
anschaut die freiheit des menschen hat
mit geht nicht von einer notwendigkeit
aus das ist ganz wichtig dass man mal
kurz zusammenfassen und jetzt wollen wir
uns noch mal hier ein paar zitate
anschauen jetzt geht es um die frage wie
stellt sich leibnitz konkret das mal um
moral vor
er hat sehr viel über das manometer
physikum gesagt und jetzt wollen wir mal
genauer schauen ließ damit aussieht wie
das zu verstehen dass in seinem system
wo jetzt gerade das zitat vor er sagt
der berühmte keppler und nachdem herr
die karte in seinen briefen haben beide
von der natürlichen trägheit der körper
gesprochen
diese trägheit nun kann man als ein von
ende des bild und als muster für die
ursprüngliche beschränktheit der
geschöpfe betrachten dann wird man sehen
dass die beraubung den formalen gehalte
unvollkommenheiten und zuträglich keiten
der substanz und ihre handlungen
ausmacht unternehmen noch ein zweites
mit dazu also er sagt hier
das können wir so mehr eine trägheit
also die trägheit die ist irgendwie das
kennzeichnen wird diesmal moral und
darin zeigt sich auch die ursprüngliche
beschränktheit die ursprüngliche
beschränktheit das ist diesmal um mit
der physik und jetzt bringt der herr
blicken das zitat des sollten uns auch
noch mal genauer anschauen um es besser
nachzuvollziehen diese metapher der
trägheit jetzt kommt eine sehr
interessante bildlich vorstellen sagt
angenommen die strömung eines flusses
trage mehrere schiffe mit verschiedener
ladungen davon die ein mit holz beladen
die anderen mit steinen die die einen
mehr die anderen weniger
hierbei werden die meisten beladenen
schiffe langsamer fahren als die anderen
vorausgesetzt dass ihn weder der wind
noch das ruder oder ein ähnliches mittel
hilft nicht eigentlich die schwer ist
die ursache dieser verzögerung da die
schiffe ihre abwärts fahren und nicht
aufsteigen sondern es ist die gleiche
ursache welche die dichterin dh jene
weniger porösen und mit dem
ihnen eigentümlichen stoffe stärker
erfüllten körper schwere machen der die
poren erfüllende stoff kann diese
bewegung nicht erhalten tritt nicht in
rechnung der stoff selbst als
ursprünglich zur trägheit oder zum
mangel an geschwindigkeit eher
verringert sie nicht durch sich selbst
weder diese geschwindigkeit schon
erhalten hat denn dann würde er handeln
aber er mindert die wirkung des
eindrucks den erhalten zur durch seine
empfänglichkeit infolgedessen muss das
schiff weil mehr materie durch dieselbe
kraft bewegt werden soll wenn es beladen
ist mit notwendigkeit langsamer fahren
auch die erfahrung über den stoß der
körper zeigen wenn man sie durch denkt
dass man doppelt so viel kraft anwenden
muss immer einen körper aus gleichen
stoff aber von doppelt der materie sich
der größe ein und dieselbe
geschwindigkeit zu erteilen was nicht
notwendig wäre wenn die materie sich
gegen ruhe und bewegung absolut
indifferent verhält wenn sie nicht jeden
erwähnte trägt bisher die ihr eine art
widerwillen gegen das bewegt werden
erteilt das wort langes zitat jetzt
überlegen wir mal gemeinsam mit
charakterisierte jetzt hier das böse als
träger wie kann man sich das jetzt
konkret vorstellen bezogen auf die
lebenswelt eine böse handeln
oder hast du noch weiter viele fragen
dazu zu diesem
inwiefern kann das böse mit der trägheit
die physikalische angelegenheit ist
die analogie gebracht werden sagt es
müssen
es ist die trägheit in der physik
überlegen sie sich mal was sagt nun er
trägt wie wir die genau beschrieben wie
redet man in der physik und die trägheit
unter welche kategorie fällt die
trägheit als phänomen in der physik
was ist die trägheit
das energie- oder was ist das für eine
kategorie beträgt
wir erwägen das in seinem leben
das leben
die machen
die mag ich nicht alles
erstens
zugegeben dass sie sich weiterbilden
selbst wenn er gut verstehen nicht nur
analysten
das spiel ist ein auto an verschiedenen
man das die reibung so groß ist dass er
den autoreifen
widerstand gibt solange sie entschieden
wenn man alles
kann man sich im klaren der welt also
wenn
der satellit noch immer wenig werden
muss braucht es dafür mehr als wenn nur
ein mensch seine kleine welt
das obwohl es noch kein widerstand keine
haltung geben so nicht
diese bewegung und noch mehr geschockt
als wenn man sich einmal einen steinigen
gebiet zwischen
dann bewegte sich weiter
es ist das ist die eigentliche träger
für dich
sozusagen zum wesen der bewegung anregen
zu sein und damit das ganze nämlich als
bild interessant dies hat dieser letzte
satz
diese letzte teil eine art widerwillen
gegen das bewegt werden man muss auch
kraft aufwenden kann man sich das jetzt
vorstellen was wäre es zu sagen das
analogon zur trägheit jetzt bezogen auf
die lebenswelt des moralisch böse
die viren können wir uns selbst in
dieser anthologie als träger verstehen
welcher hinsicht hand sind wir träge
wenn wir zu viel gegessen haben sind wir
träge aber das ist damit nicht gemeint
nach dem lösen
man kann es jetzt mal auf das mal um auf
diese drei maler beziehen also wo zeigt
sich hier in diesen drei maler die
trägheit könnte man ihn zu fragen
mindestens
diese kleine
das richtig also das manometer physikum
ist die prinzipielle endlichkeit die
aber eben auch in sich schließt das wir
böse handelt böse im moralischen sinne
böse handeln könnten endlich gewesen
besitzen die möglichkeit gleich jetzt
böse zu haben weil sie begrenzt sind
unendlich gewesen wo nicht ja also gott
zumindest nicht ja gott hat kein mangel
gott vergleicht sich nicht mit anderen
gott findet nicht neid
aber die götter die götter leibnitz hat
eben nur einen einen gott und er denkt
eben doch denke ich den christlichen
gott oder den den britischen gott diesen
auch sehr moralisch konnotierten
gottesbegriff
aber zurück zu der frage wir haben jetzt
mal bei marco moral wenn wir mal ganz
konkret
sie haben etwas böses getan moralisch
verwerflich eine sünde so was böses wir
wirklich fast gelöst wo die anderen
sagen das war böse inwiefern hat es
jetzt was mit der trägheit zu tun
ja
ich denke ihr gefällt
unsere
verhindert
also eine widerständigkeit gegenüber dem
guten das wäre jetzt also das böse über
das gute her definiert
vom guten her gesehen und wir haben das
auch schon bei anderen denkern die wir
behandelt hatten gesehen
diese denke die vom guten ausgehen und
daran dann das böse bemessen aber das
böse wäre hier das wenige was so träge
ist dass es dem ruf des guten nicht
folgt oder sich von guten nicht bewegen
lässt das sich selbst trägt den bösen
auch irgendwie wieder setzt als eine art
wider willen gegenüber dem bewegt werden
durch das gute würden sie sah so könnte
man das doch interpretiert wer war das
richtig wiedergegeben genau und jetzt
kann man sich fragen welche
grundauffassung des bösen liegt dann
zugrunde
wenn jetzt das böse am guten gemessen
wird wie viel es dem guten entgegenkommt
und da haben wir gesehen dass das wohl
eher eine art von privat ions theorie
das böse ist ein mangel an mobilität
gegenüber dem rubel
das böse ist das wenige was auf sich
gehabt und da bekomme dann auch noch
viele interessante nehmen zu anderen
denker die jetzt noch kommen zur
schelling und auch zur kirche gok ihr
gesagt das böse hat sowas trotziges
trotziges es ist jedenfalls ein
widerwille im guten zu folgen es beharrt
auf sich
das ist die spannende frage inwiefern
ist diese widerwille gegen das bewegt
werden was wird als das gute aufgefasst
haben ihm wieder wie fern ins dieser
widerwille selbst etwas positives in
büchern ist also dass nicht nur so eine
passive trägheit ich bin jetzt halt zu
schwer oder zu träge um bewegt zu werden
das wäre jetzt diese diese analogie die
frage die man jetzt stellen kann ist die
inwiefern es diese trägheit selbst
willentlich und aktiv also wie fern ist
es eine bewusste eine bewusste
entgegensetzen gegen diesen strom des
des guten
gegen diese anziehungskraft des guten
kann sich das so vorstellen dass gute
zieht uns an und wir setzen uns ihm
entgegen
frage wie setzen uns im gegenteil wir
träge sind weil wir halt so sind von
natur aus oder leistungen wir widerstand
auf eine gewisse weise das scheint hier
noch ein bisschen offen zu bleiben weil
wenn es nämlich ein aktives widerstand
ausüben gegen dem die anziehung des
guten wäre dann wäre es so eine art von
perversion story jedenfalls dann wäre es
nicht mehr eine prävention theorie also
hier an ist jetzt der sitzt genau die
frage wie dieser widerwille als trägheit
zu verstehen ist ich glaube hier hatte
sich noch jemand gemeldet auf dieser
seite oder hier ganz hinten ja sie haben
sich gerade noch gemeldet wollten sie
auch in diese richtung was sagen oder
da habe ich noch habe noch jemand
übersehen
wir lesen
der dafür benötigte ziehen wollte die
hat man wenn man diese gehört
sicher habt ihr auch den charakter des
widerstände sträubt sich dagegen
bezogen werden denn es gibt kein wunder
ist wenn sie heute an sieben kraft aus
eigentlich müssten sich eben voll
arbeitet irgendwas freut sich an 100
motive aber diese nichts außer dass sie
meister
das ist nicht sehr aktives insofern gibt
es in dem wieder weg ist kommt er aber
davor muss man sich jetzt sind diese
kräfte gegen diese lokomotive schon
wieder aus sich machen kann so ein
störrischer interaktiven gezogen werden
will
darum und lieben macht es nicht diese
casting aber dennoch stolz dass ich weiß
nicht was man einen sich sträuben dass
ich finde die ganze klasse begleitet uns
das thema da ist in den kategorien
einbringen die an die wand ist das
aktive und passive handy gleich gemacht
sich damit letztendlich so ein bisschen
worden ist lassen sich
völlig richtig völlig die leibniz
schwankt er hat eigentlich von seiner
rahmenbedingungen herne präventions-
theorie privates ziel das bild ist ein
mangel an guten auch ökologisch
untergeordnet aber hier in diesen
widerwillen steckt schon so eine art von
aktivität und das würde jetzt ein
hinweis sein
auch eine perversion theorie wir lesen
noch ein zitat dann kommen wir gleich
auf die diskussion zurück war jetzt
vergleicht das vergleichen jetzt die
kraft die der strom auf die schiffe
ausübt und mitgeteilt mit der tätigkeit
gottes die alles positive in den
kreaturen erzeugt und erhält und in
vollkommenheit existenz und kraft gibt
vergleichen wir sage ich die trägheit
der materie mit der natürlichen
unvollkommenheit die kreaturen und das
langsame fahren des beladenen schiffes
mit dem mangel den wir in den
beschaffenheiten und der tätigkeit der
kreaturen antreffen so werden wir finden
dass es kaum etwas treffenderes gibt als
diesen vergleich die strömung ist die
ursache für die bewegung des schiffes
aber keineswegs für ihre verzögerung
jetzt kommt der vergleich gott ist die
ursache für die vollkommenheit in der
natur und in handlung der kreaturen aber
die beschränkte reaktivität der kreatur
ist die ursache für die menge auf die
wir bei ihrer tätigkeit stoßen und die
mängel sind jetzt ebenso wohl sünden
oder böse handlungen als auch
krankheiten
frage haben sie passt das trifft dass
ihre intuition das böse und der sünde
jetzt mein konkret bezug auf das man um
moral
der einerseits kann
die kamera dabei
richtig sie sagten er neigt dazu erst
hatten sie gesagt er kann gar nicht
anders und haben sie es ein bisschen
relativiert man gesagt eine neigung
neigung tendenz und man könnte es auch
schon im vorgriff auf kant den wir jetzt
der zweiten hälfte lesen wir einen hang
nennen
es gibt einen hang oder eine schlagseite
anhang ist noch nicht die notwendigkeit
des bösen zu tun
es gibt eine tendenz in innere tendenz
eine orientierung dahin so eine art
anziehungskraft seine gravitationskraft
des welt der physikalisch die dorthin
graviert vom bösen vom guten weg aber es
ist nicht die notwendigkeit und wir
fragen uns dann das ganze auch diese
diese vergleichs ebene der physik die
scheint auch so eine art determinismus
vorausgesetzt wo bleibt dann die
freiheit kann man sich doch fragen
ist die freiheit nicht ihr müsst die
freiheit diesen wider willen
aufzubringen uns liegen
da kann man das adäquat mit dieser
trägheit wiedergeben
sozusagen
richtig als seine auffassung von
trägheit wäre alleine widerborstigkeit
wobei auch so eine reaktion sind
widerwille als reaktion was positives
haben könnte wenn man sich überlegt es
gibt da so ein gebot zumal die zehn
gebote und diese zehn gebote provozieren
ich beschränke mich an meine
individualität denken sie an augustinus
dieses birnen diesen birnen diebstahl
ich glaube auch dass man diesen birnen
diebstahl bei augustinus als so eine art
trotzreaktion interpretieren kann sie
können darüber diskutieren gegenüber dem
siebten gebot ich glaube das ist so
sollst nicht stehlen
du sollst dich spielen es ist eine
reaktion die widerwille gegen dieses
gebot dass er nicht stehen soll
er stiehlt die birne weiter dieses gebot
über treten soll
zu interpretieren ist ebenfalls weil er
sich nicht einschränken lassen möchte
könnte man nicht so auch die trägheit
interpretieren
seine mannschaft der liga
doch diese erwägungen
ja das trifft eben auf menschen zu aber
tiere trifft jedenfalls dass man ihm
physikum tiere sind krank am tag halten
die moralische kategorie dass man moral
trifft nicht auf tiere zu würde leibnitz
sagen die sind nicht frei also können
sie auch nicht von diesem mann um moral
betroffen seien aber das mal um physikum
kann eben tiere betreffen weil tiere
endliche existenzen sind können sie
krank wird
inwiefern das denn auf die trägheit
zurückgeführt werden kann das ist eine
spannende frage
dann bitte noch das andere nicht aus
sicherlich nichts bekommen das ja aber
eben nicht aus notwendigkeit das böse
das ist eben wichtig dieser unterschied
nicht aus notwendigkeit das sagt dann an
anderer stelle diese ganzen mal folgende
aus dieser ursprünglichen begrenztheit
nicht notwendigerweise weil sonst wäre
die freiheit verloren also nur die
möglichkeit eine notwendige möglichkeit
aber nicht die notwendigkeit das ist
notwendigerweise möglich aber es liegt
in unserer freiheit letztendlich ob wir
die sünde beginnt das böse tun
denn man hat
ich schon
kommentieren
[Applaus]
die frage stellt sich dann die sitzen
konkreten entscheidungen sagt aus wie
sieht's so aus eine spannende frage
bleibt sagt dazu auch was in einer
anderen schrift vor sich immer mehr mit
der willensfreiheit befasst sein wo sie
sales einen neuen es also als reaktion
auf die theorie von john glock hatte
eine freiheits theorie entwickelt ein
wildes freiheits theorie die müsste man
sich genauer anschauen auf die können
wir jetzt nicht eingehen wenn sie eine
hausarbeit schreiben wollen würde sich
zu empfehlen diese zwei stiften also die
theodizee und die sind wo sie
zusammenzubringen zuschauen geht das
ganze auf sie hat zu sagen zwei
annäherungsweise nan das bös einmal
diese eher metaphysische
herangehensweise von gott aus sondern
von oben das ist dann eine perspektive
aus der das böse als trägheit erscheint
weil es von oben letztendlich darauf
geworfen wird die perspektive
dann gibt es eine gegenläufige tendenz
der betrachtung des bösen von unten
gewissermaßen von der menschlichen
willens freiheiten und das macht diesen
niveaus serie
könnten sie mal versuchen das wäre ein
mögliches thema aber wir haben noch ein
zitat oder haben wir jetzt jemanden hier
vergessen der noch was zu dieser frage
sagen wollte
damit ist man noch immer ein zitat
zeigte nämlich so hielten die
platonischer sankt augustin und die
scholastik also thomas von aquin denen
wir auch behandelt hatten
mit recht gott für die ursache der
materie des bösen etwas positives
darstellen und nicht für die ursache der
form muss ist glaube ich heißen die in
einer privaten besteht wie man die
strömung für die ursache der materie
aber nicht der form der verzögerung
halten kann das heißt sie ist die
ursache der geschwindigkeit des schiffes
ohne damit auch die ursache für die
grenzen diese geschwindigkeit sein und
ebenso wie dies ebenso wenig wie die
strömung des flusses ursache der
verlangsamten fahrt des schiffes ist ist
gott ursache der sünde was die kraft der
materie
das ist der geist dem fleisch der geist
ist willig aber das fleisch ist schwach
werden noch ein spot gibt der kreatur
und erzeugt dauernd immer nur das
positive gute und vollkommene in ihr da
jede vollkommene gabe zum vater des
lichts kommt
während unvollkommenheiten und menge der
handlungen aus der ursprünglichen
begrenzung stammen und mit der 5
sekunden
die die kreatur durch die sie
beschränken den idealen gründe von
anbeginn ihrer existenz erhalten musste
dann haben wir uns diesmal und
metaphysik und gott konnte ihr nicht
alles geben ohne sie zum gott zu machen
er musste also stufe weise unterschiede
der verkommenheit der dinge und eben zu
beschränkungen jeder art geben
als gott konnte das war die anfangs
frage konnte keine perfekte kreatur
schaffen
das würde ihm selbst widersprechen
gut kann nur etwas schaffen was nicht er
selbst ist als schöpfen und damit einher
geht das manometer physikum dass es
diese beschränktheit und der möglichkeit
nach dass mal um moral und dass man für
sie aber eben nicht der notwendigkeit
einmal im leben hat
möglichkeit
ja also die theorie ist noch wesentlich
komplexer wir haben jetzt nur teile
betrachtet in der zusammenfassung haben
wir es geschrieben die sie bekommen
haben
wir hatten es ganz kurzes letztes mal
erwähnt bleibt sagt in gott ist der
verstand und der wille
und dann haben wir die ganzen anderen
prädikate allmächtig
ungültig
und noch aldi sind und der verstandene
wille in gott
die beiden zusammen genommen die führen
dann zu der konkreten gestaltung der
welt der verstand gottes ist
notwendigerweise so beschaffen dass er
nur endliche wesen erzeugen kann
weil alles andere würde den begriff
gottes widersprechen kann nicht sich
selbst schaffen und der wille gottes ist
so dass er angesichts dieser notwendigen
begrenztheit das beste will im
zusammenspiel von verstand und wille
kommt also nach lebens die beste aller
möglichen welten zustande
man könnte sagen dessen art kompromiss
der wille angesichts der logischen
vorgaben der verstand da will er will
nur das beste
das ist also die alge ist im willen zu
finden und im zusammenspiel dieser zwei
vermögen könnte man sagen entsteht dann
letztendlich die beste aller möglichen
welten
ja das war ja auch in der 2
du bist auf
was gerade neben der position aus und
wenn man dort ja
sofern
das ist ganz weg
richtig also jemand wir hatten darüber
diskutiert wir hatten dort ist es bei
spiel gebracht und diesen chef der seine
mitarbeiter nicht kontrolliert jeder
hinsicht der also alles festlegt das
wäre eine freiheitsbeschränkung sondern
chef der sagt ich lasse euch die
freiheit und in dem der chef die
mitarbeiter nicht so sehr kontrolliert
sondern freiheit lässt zeigt der chef
gerade seine souveränität ist seine
bedeutung erleben nicht abhängig ist von
den mitarbeitern und ihnen vertraut also
das würde auch denke jeder führungs
manager sagen ein chef der drei
mitarbeiter möglichst viel freiheit gibt
ist der bessere chef als der der jede
noch so kleine tätigkeit kontrollieren
also der fifa auch freiheit setzt das
schränkt jetzt gottes allmacht nicht ein
dass er den menschen freiheit verleiten
wir sehen also bei leibnitz hängt das
böse mit einem viel größeren kontext
zusammen
diese mahnung metaphysik um das beste
die beste aller möglichen welten ist
also metaphysisches system und
entscheiden dass hier diese
zusammenwirkung von verstand um willen
daraus ergibt sich dann besser
ermöglichen werden als eine art von
kompromiss als einen austarieren
des willens der wähler will nur das gute
aber der wille ist gebunden an den
verstand der verstand ist gibt es
eigentlich von der endlichen schöpfung
und im zusammenspiel dieser zwei
vermögen könnte man sagen kommt dann am
ende die beste aller möglichen welten
heraus ist die beste und auch noch
wichtig den superlativ oder irgendwie
auch so eine art komparativ es gebe noch
andere mögliche welten aber angesichts
der anderen möglichen welten ist diese
welt in der wir leben immer noch die
beste
und
da rolle spielen
also dagegen das material die etwas
aussagt und so eingesetzt hat ist was
diese bilder abschreiten
vom gelernten gottes zum menschen sobald
er wieder geschieden doch auch die
möglichkeit meine homepage
und waren zu schützen
weil das salomon
eineinhalb jahre
weil hier
richtig aber eben jetzt nicht die
materie als sein gegen prinzip im sinne
dass man nicht es muss ihnen sich wir
hatten das ganze zu beginn auch bei
luther man nicht harris muss das gute
und das böse und das böse wird er mit
der materie gleichgesetzt das gute mit
dem licht und so denkt das leibnitz
nicht als er wenige sagt das böse ist
irgendwie der materie
dann muss man immer noch dazu sagen dass
das nicht der eigentliche grund des
bösen ist die materie sondern der
eigentliche grund liegt im metaphysik
und das sagt bleibt uns das ist die
ideale verfassung ideal sich im guten
sinne sind die metaphysische
konditionierung des menschen darin liegt
der eigentliche grund des bösen dass der
mensch endlich ist und damit einher geht
natürlich auch die materie mit der
endlichkeit geht die material her die
materie ist dass endlich die physik
behandelt die physis betrifft das werden
und vergehen das ist endlichkeit aber
der grund ist jetzt nicht ein
metaphysisches prinzip der materie was
dem guten gegenübersteht von der grund
ist das manometer physikum und der kunde
sind eligible zu finden das ist also ein
wichtiger wichtige unterschied gegenüber
platon die materie in ihrer endlichkeit
folgt aus dem mahnung metaphysik und
nicht als ein dunkles gegen prinzipien
manieristische tradition davon grenzt
sich leibnitz abgesehen man kommt hier
vom hölzchen auf stöckchen das ein
riesen system wir wollten hier nochmals
als zusammenfassung der letzten sitzung
hinweisen auf diesen sehr sehr
problematischen begriff der trägheit zu
sprechen kommen und wie die kommilitonen
auch richtig sagte
immer wieder bilden gibt es diese zwei
tendenzen es gibt einerseits eine
trägheit ist eine passivität ich lasse
mich nicht bewegen ich stehe so da wie
so eine lokomotive auf der anderen seite
seite ist darin auch der aktivität
enthalten ich setze mich mit dem guten
entgleiste widerstand wie wir es gesehen
haben drinnen diebstahl von augustinus
und letztendlich schreibt uns diese
frage offen zu lassen
wie genau diese widerständigkeit zu
verstehen ist
[Musik]
er hatte sich den ursprung
aber dann
hier speziell hier steht
schon deswegen dem spiel
anschließend werden
als sonst
unterscheidet zwischen geistes
kleine party und der welt sind geister
materie beziehungsweise seele und
material
das ist dieser grund genannt technologie
das kleinste kleine
nicht passiert ihr zeichen in wieder der
geist als kontroll- und 20
mono oder kontrollieren sondern jedes
kleinste teil der welt ist deshalb
bilden zu können
sieben diese mit einer sind
was die materie des körpers kontrolliert
das unternehmen
ein kormoran aus kleinsten seelen
gefunden markiert
also es eigentlich
ein
diese ambition gedacht also
natrium kreisstadt sind keine zeilen
macher verbinde
passt auch ganz gut zu fragen
das physikum zu der theorie fast 200
aber noch nicht geben
diese stoffe sind
jetzt haben
der weise dass die ameise stärke ist es
kann man auch anträge hat mir schreiben
die materie nicht zu sehr menschlich
denkt im sinne von organza aufstehen und
suchen sondern sich wirklich als einen
absoluten widerständigkeit man schämt
sich dass gott die ameise wirklich
perfekt ausgestattet das heißt auch
eigentlich mit einem der schränke wunsch
der alt ist der effekt funktioniert
und warum diese als sie jemals nicht den
bauhof kommen nicht mehr haben nicht
mehr arbeiten kann sondern stört dass
die anfälle eigentlich ihre trägheit
auch in physischen sinne nämlich dass
ihr körper als dieses nicht in der lage
den perfekten im urzustand der in von
gott gegeben nur dauerhaft
aufrechtzuerhalten
irgendwann auf zu schlagen
und jetzt kommen sie obwohl keine
negative macht kein übel das haus statt
könnten
normal sind keine karte
ist ein mensch der noch irgendwann auf
zu schlagen
was letztes genau vorzuschlagen einen
seltsamen möglichkeit und sagte einmal
dass schwächen
völlig richtig
in diesem sinne würde es klappen bei
altersschwäche sozusagen
da läuft das leben dann aus da kann das
leben nicht mit dem strom folgen
letztendlich es ist bleibt irgendwie am
rand es wird weggespült oder so nass
bleibt verfängt sich am rand und volk
nicht mit dem strom
anders ist es dann bei anderen
erkrankungen krebs erkrankungen zum
beispiel tumoren die eben nicht mehr in
meinen augen diese bloße trägheit
besitzen wie ein auslaufendes lebens an
die eigene positivität dem leben
entgegensetzen dem sie ein falsches
leben nämlich konstituieren
also dass zum beispiel das ist auf
menschen ständig mutationen das sei
alles abwehrkräften hier ständig
bekämpfen
nach einer krebserkrankung ist ja nur
dass der körper sozusagen dazu nicht
mehr in der lage in die sucht werden auf
dem perfekt ausgestattet das wesen eines
was eigentlich in allen stationen halt
wissen und krankheiten geben uns recht
kommt und es ist eine ausdrucksform von
physischer trägheit dass er sozusagen
die sind diese widerstandskraft
aber wenn man sich eben diese bestimmte
erkrankungen anschaut sind es eben nicht
nur mängel würde ich jetzt sagen
schelling kommt darauf zu sprechen
deswegen macht die punkte zu stark
sondern besitzen krankheiten eher eine
form von positivität könnte man sagen
indem sie ein falsches leben
konzentrieren
wenn man sich mal anschaut was das für
blüten treibt jetzt mal ein bisschen
metaphorisch gesprochen welt wie
wucherungen extreme ausmaße annehmen
können die den ganzen körper vor und
starten
da scheint dann schon so eine art von
gegenmacht mit dem spiel zu sein die
nicht mehr glaube ich nur als eine
trägheit gefasst werden kann das ist die
spannende frage zu stürzen
das ist die frage halt also
genau als ich glaube das ist ein guter
wendepunkt ich glaube das können wir
festhalten bleibt es ist ein wendepunkt
wie sie es beschrieben hatten dieser
widerwille wie fassen wir ihn
es ist nur eine trägheit an sich
entgegen setzen das eher passiv ist oder
ist diese trägheit ein aktiver
widerwille so wie es schon bei august
insgesamt wurde und kant den wir jetzt
genau behandelt werden und aber auch vor
allem schelling die betonen die
positivität des bösen die sagen dieser
widerwille der ist nicht nur eine
passivität sondern ist eine aktivität
die ganz bewusst den guten etwas
entgegensetzt die gute ordnung auf den
kopf stellt bitte
die träger ist beschränkt also mit
das war die frage kommilitonin vorhin da
muss doch so ein indifferent der zustand
vorhanden sein auf dem man erst die
selbstbestimmung erfolgt erst mal von
der anderen perspektive haben schauen
wir uns mal die böse handlung das war ja
auch die frage die böse handlung konkret
dann haben wir bis jetzt nicht genau
betrachtet was ist eine böse handlung
wenn jemanden anderen aus neid aus noch
einmal ganz blattes beispiel aus neid
aus habgier und tötet man seinen besitz
zu kommen da würde die meisten sagen das
ist moralisch verwerflich
die christlichen oder religiösen gründen
sagen ist eine sünde du sollst nicht
töten du sollst stehende sind zwei
gebote gleich verletzt worden darin ich
denke das würde jeder sagen dass so was
nicht okay ist und dass das moralisch
verwerflich jemand anderen zu töten wenn
man sie lebt sein geld zu kommen
und jetzt die frage inwiefern zeigt sich
in so einer handlung eine trägheit in
büchern zeigt sich in wien hat diese
handlung die ja durchaus was aktives ist
die signatur der trägt sich finden sie
die sport in seiner hand
für anna zusammen aber das ist der
hammer
okay sie sagen es zurück und dieses
nachgeben dieser trägheit das müsste
doch mal was zusätzliches genau da kommt
dann der wille ein spieler der die frage
ist dass nicht noch etwas drittes was
jetzt hier gar nicht behandelt wurde
aber könnte man nicht sagen dass dieses
dieses töten eines menschen aus habgier
dass das eben selbst die gestalt einer
trägheit jetzt im doppelten sinne eines
widerwillens und eines sich hingeben es
ist könnte man es nicht auch noch mehr
in aktiven sind verstehen ich dachte
jetzt ebenso an dieses augustin ische
moment da gibt es jetzt ein gebot du
sollst nicht töten oder schwer so ein
bisschen ab du sollst nicht stehlen und
dieses gebot provoziert mich provoziert
mich aber natürlich muss ich dann sagen
sie das provoziert mich das ist der
widerwille aber um dann tatsächlich es
zu betreten musste noch im feiern
schluss hinzukommen denn meine freiheit
zu brechen
frage kann dieser freien entschluss
dieses gebot zu vertreten aufgelöst
werden auf die trägheit kann das als
basis letztendlich darf als erklärungs
grund dafür die ist es hinreichend
das war die frage der kommunion auch
ihre fragen die sehr berechtigt diese
frage ob das wirklich so eine böse
handlung angemessen beschreibt diese
trägheit oder ob mich noch irgendwie so
ein zusätzliches momente zu kommen
müssen dass da nicht irgendwie der
trägheit führen
ich glaube eben schon das video auch
sagt dass das lebens aus guten gründen
diese trägheit um sind dieses
widerwillens gewählt hat weil es zwei
seiten hat trägt das hat die passivität
ich schreib sie trägt
und er nennt auch an einer anderen
stelle die die trägheit kraft fichte
will johann gottlieb fichte der deutsche
teil ist der wird ein ganz ähnliches
bild des bösen werfen er wird dann auf
die trägheit kraft zu sprechen kann sagt
heizkraft und darin haben wir dann schon
mehr das positiv ist eine kraft
antriebskraft eine trägheit kann einmal
passivität sein und einmal widerwille
widerstand widerstand wieder
wieder will hier haben wir in diesem
zitat auf seit 116 widerwillen gegen das
gebiet für also ich glaube darin haben
wir wirklich diese diese ambivalenz der
trägheit
das hat was passives objekt also
praktisch passivität und das ist
aktivität
dann
[Applaus]
werden
fal si
weil ein land
also der
so wenig zu wenig stark
das hat etwas ganz ähnliches diese
ambivalenz wie das nichts sie nennen
sich noch das nichts
bei thomas einmal nichts
praktisch oder sowas hab einmal
das nichts oder so nichts kann ich
nichts darüber sagen dass nichts auf der
anderen seite wird substantiiert das
nichts als es doch etwas fragen das
nicht immer so bezeichnen da ist nichts
passier zwischen etwas und nichts und
die trägheit ist glaube ich ganz
ähnliches sie changiert zwischen
passivität von zwischen aktivität
zwischen widerwillen trick sei nicht so
träge
mach doch mal was sich so rum steht auf
macht doch was soll das denn der sport
sei nicht träge du bist schuld weil du
so bist du siehst du die ganze zeit
du willst nicht du hast diese
einstellung hat es auch häufig so ein
vorwurf drin wenn man jemand trägheit
vorwirft
und ich denke das ist ein ähnliches bild
und das ist aber auch ein problem bei
leibnitz wie es uns scheint weil es
vielleicht absichtlich oder nicht
absichtlich in eine ambivalenz
hineinmanövriert die dann diese
weitergehenden fragen irgendwie versucht
zu klären auf einen schlag werden
jedenfalls sehen dass diese frage nach
die aktivität die ein riesenproblem
verleiht mit darstellt nicht zuletzt
auch deswegen weil es in seinem ganzen
kosmos letztendlich
durch auszusondern stärkeren
einschränkungen gottes führen würde wenn
jetzt da individuen sind das wirklich im
modus die aktivität vollziehen nicht
mehr modus der passivität von 10 des
mangels das würde dann wieder eine
stärke gegenständlichkeit gegenüber gott
ermöglichen wir haben der letzten
sitzung gesagt eigentlich widerspricht
es gar nicht gottes allmacht wenn man es
mal konsequenter denkt die tatsache dass
gott geschafft die so autonom sind dass
es sich im selbst gegenüber stellen ihn
kritisieren in frage stellen
beleidigen könnte gerade für die
allmacht gottes sprechen also dass
solche individuen zuletzt oder peter wie
siehst du aus theologischer sicht
widerspricht
das scheint jetzt leid mit so noch nicht
genau zu sehen aber das wäre eine
tendenz die möglichkeit diese aktivität
bisschen stärker zu portieren des bösen
und damit auch die freiheit des
individuums im guten und vor allem bösen
stärker zu machen
nicht in den stärker kürzen und zwar
erfolge aufweisen
für besagte diese
und auch zu den xi an der elmos lose
gezogen
sich immer was zu greifen und dadurch
sind wir alle ausgestaltet und natürlich
unterbieten
dollar
der bewährte der menschen
es wundert uhr
kultur lesen und eine spur der erziehung
also pleon ixia wäre dann mit trägheit
zu vergleichen
mit der stadt
sie grüßen zu machen und hier sind sehr
sehr nett
so viel heißt dieses sehe ich denke das
geht ganz in die richtung von leibnitz
vielleicht noch ein letztes wort zur
leibniz zeigten einer anderen schrift
der confessio philosophie können sie
auch mal sich anschauen sagt leibnitz
das böse ist so wie wenn man das licht
sieht man aber nicht folgen möchte wenn
man eine hilfe angeboten bekommt und sie
aus schlägt so müsste man sich das große
vorstellung und der hamas dann aber
wieder hilfe angeboten bekommen sie
auszuschlagen hat einerseits diese
trägheit ich bin dagegen nicht reagiere
nicht auf hat aber auch dieses aktive
moment nicht annehmen dass ausschlag
die worden
richtig genau die höhle wo es ist
höhengleich ist ein sehr guter
bezugspunkt auch für das böse die
höhlenbewohner die wollen gar nicht
draußen die werden gezwungen die werden
gezwungen von jemandem der sie dann
hochtreibt
alles tut weh aber das ist jetzt eine
frage die er auf das gute zielt habe ich
ja noch ein seminar über das gute da
spielen dann solche punkte noch eine
stärkere habe ich denke da trifft dann
platon tatsächlich auch auf leibnitz zu
sehen hier kann man sehr sehr schön
diskutieren und das eignet sich
natürlich auch als für ein haus
arbeitsthema diese frage nach der
trägheit und jetzt kommen wir zum
eigentlich für unser thema der moderne
jedenfalls wichtigsten philosophen
immanuel kant er hat auch viel
geschrieben wir haben das letzte mal ein
referat gehört wird die hintergründe von
kant wir wollen uns auf einen schrift
beschränken nämlich die religionen da
hat der grenzenlosen vernunft hat auch
noch andere werke geschrieben aber
dieser schrift die wir jetzt lesen
auszugsweise da sagte am meisten über
das böse und er sagt zum beispiel man
kann sich zum beispiel fragen was kann
und im radikal bösen der menschennatur
versteht er prägt diesen begriff des
radikal bösen er unterscheidet zwischen
verschiedenen stufen des bösen
verschiedene grade und er spricht von
einem hang zum lösen und diese hat der
ist ganz ähnlich wie diese trägheit
man hat auch so eine schlagseite das hat
sowas von einer tiefen der gebildete wo
man sich fragt da ist dieses schiefe
gebildet diese schiefe konstruktion kann
man die überhaupt noch im freiheits
theoretischen sinne verstehe das nicht
fehlkonstruktion wenn etwas einen hang
hat dieses schiff hat eine schlagseite
inwiefern hat das was mit freiheit zu
tun das ist dann eine ähnliche
metaphorik wie die rede von der trägheit
der hand die trägheit sind metaphern
hannes nicht ist eine metapher
das ist keine eigentliche bezeichnet
genauso wie die trägheit eigentlich auch
inwiefern treffen solche metaphern des
wesen des bösen vor allem dann wenn es
nicht nur im sinne des mal um das der
privatteams theorie des bloßen mangels
an guten des mangels an zeit verstanden
werden soll sondern im sinne etwas
aktiven einer perversion inwiefern
passen solche metaphern dann noch
angesichts dieser phänomene
ja ja sagt gleich am anfang so ist die
frage ob nicht ein mittleres wenigstens
möglich sein nämlich dass der mensch in
seiner gattung weder gut noch böse oder
allenfalls auch eines sowohl als das
andere zum teil zum teil gut zum teil
böse sein können
das ist jetzt eine interessante frage
das betrifft die frage der hat die akura
dia vor heißt es ist nur drakonische
handlung sind weder gut noch böse
schreibt geheiratet
das ist einfach prima team um heißt
nicht und die affäre ihn heißt
unterscheiden unterteilen das ist das
nicht unser teilbare in gut und böse
gibt es moralische neutrale handeln zb
dass ich jetzt gerade unterricht hier
diese handlungen jetzt hier was zusammen
mit herrn schütt zu vermitteln ist ja
ein handlungen unterrichten müssen die
handlung ist diese fragen gut oder böse
ist diese haltung gut oder böse da
würden wir jetzt vielleicht sagen er gut
aber weil es ja um es böse geht
vielleicht auch ein bisschen böse
naja irgendwie seltsam kann man nicht so
genau sagen oder wenn ich jetzt etwas
esse nahrungsaufnahme ist ja auch eine
handlung frage wie steht es damit ist
ein anderes thema kann man sich stellen
wichtiger ist jetzt folgen das hat er
darauf kommt
man nennt aber einen menschen böse ich
darum weil der handlungen aus und welche
böse oder gesetzeswidrig sind weil diese
so beschaffen sind dass sie auch bösen
maximen in ihm schließen lassen und das
letzte mal hatte ich schon mal ein
schema eingezeichnet sie haben den
menschen wir haben die handlung und wir
haben die maxime
es geht jetzt endlich als um das objekt
des prädikats büßen
die referenz genau genommen weil wir
haben hier ein wort wohl auf was bezieht
sich das wort auf mensch was ist hier
verrät referenz das modus böse sagt toll
wie das ist ein böser mensch man sagen
viele und ich glaube auch zu recht
jedenfalls scheint es mir so wir sollten
nie menschen als böse bezeichnet
menschen als solchen
das ist ein klischee böse handlungen wie
sieht es damit aus kann man handlungen
bösen prima partie schon mensch da wäre
hier so der kandidat etr täter
kenner sind böse menschen gut aber wenn
man ein täter bestimmtem ein täter
dingfest macht und sagt man gut der
mensch ist deswegen böse oder insofern
nyse einzelner böse handlung oder
handlungen verübt hat ein verbrechen
verübt hat jetzt sagt er bekannt nicht
darum meine handlungen aus übliche
gesetzes mäßig oder böse sind sondern er
sagt weil sie so beschaffen sind die
handlungen dass sie auch lösen maximen
in ihm schließen lassen
das ist normal sehr interessant das ist
ein schluss ist dann schluss
kant scheint das diskutieren kann
scheint damit sozusagen das böse im
eigentlichen sinne
das ist nicht personifiziert das sind
keine menschen das sind eigentlich auch
keine handlungen die wir sehen können
der behält die vampire objektivieren
können die wir vielleicht sogar auch
naturwissenschaftlich beschreiben
könnten also diese phänomenale ebene
feld wächst das böse jedenfalls nach
diesem zitat sonne sind produkte oder
objekte eines schlosses hat der status
des jähnigen was eigentlich böse ist das
höchst prekär system ist theologisch
also wir haben hier ein malz einerseits
jene bisher ist die und logie könnte man
sagen der onkologie was kann alles bösen
die objekte die referenzobjekte des
wortes böse das ist die ontologie und
hier würde ich sagen hier auf dieser
ebene haben wir diese technologie
die erkenntnis theoretische frage
wie erkennen wir dass kriterien oder
definitorischen könnte man auch sagen
entscheidend ist also hier die maxime
das ist das eigentliche objekt des bösen
oder das eigentlich eigentliche referenz
des wortes böses zurückgenommen und die
können wir gar nicht sehen sagt kann da
noch einen weiteren zeit so die müssen
wir uns erschließen
darauf können wir nur schließen das ist
nochmal maxime das papier setzte man
schon mal kurz besprochen haben sie eine
idee was was wäre jetzt konkret gefragt
mit böse maxime böse handlung haben auch
schon mal geklärt ich jemand eine person
erlitt eine person b aus habgier
ausleiht um irgendwie sich zu
bemächtigen
das ist eine böse handeln erkannten nein
wir sollten nicht die handlung lösen
sondern wir sollten die zugrunde
liegende maxime was ist jetzt mit
maximal sind böse maxime
ja
genau also immer wenn ich einen vorteil
davon mir verschaffen kann und für
kinder hinzufügen wenn es keine
schlechten konsequenzen für mich hart
wenn ich es so tun kann dass es niemand
merkt dann lüge ich dann sag ich dir
ungehalten
das wäre noch kein typischer fall einer
bösen maxim
ja nach kant wäre utilitarismus also die
theorie dass der nutzen des der grad des
guten ist das kriterium des guten wäre
verkannt problematisch weil er auch zu
beginn seine grundlegung zur metaphysik
der sitten sagt gut ist allein nur ein
guter wille das kann man hier vielleicht
auch noch kontrastieren gut und der
wille wiederum ist eben hier die maximum
also dass größe bezieht sich auch hier
auf dem bild ein
genau so einen guten gut sich die
handlung gut ist die maxime die eine
handlung zugrunde legt ich denke dass
schon mal ganz interessant von anfang zu
sehen worauf er jetzt dass das böse hier
richtet wurde es böse vor ort sagte
weiter und kann man zwar gesetzeswidrige
handlungen durch erfahrung bemerken auch
wenigstens an sich selbst dass sie mit
bewusstsein gesetzwidrig sind aber die
maximen kann man nicht beobachten also
auch nicht in planung so gar nicht alle
mal in sich selbst mithin das urteil
dass der täter ein böser mensch sei
nicht mit sicherheit aus erfahrung
gründen
also müsste sich aus einigen ja aus
einer einzigen mit bewusstsein bösen
handlung apriori auf eine böse zum
grunde liegende maxime und aus dieser
auf ein in dem subjekt allgemein
liegenden grund aller moralisch das
aller aller besonderen moralisch bösen
handlungen der selbst wiederum maxime
ist schließen lassen um einen menschen
böse zu nennen als wir müssen jetzt hier
noch etwas hinzufügen also konkrete
maxime baca
grete maxime oder maxime erster stufe
und da müsste man noch mal hier drauf
wachsen jetzt weiter stützen
also das ist eine konkrete maxime
insofern maxime überhaupt konkret sein
könntest du fragen aber da müsste noch
mal eine viel grundlegendere maxime
erschlossen werden auf basis dieser
wachsen
und er sagt ganz interessant wir können
nicht mehr bei uns selbst feststellen ob
wir jetzt hier eine böse handlung
bezogen haben auch wenn er böse maxime
gehabt haben die maximen kann man nicht
beobachten nicht so gar nicht alle mal
in sich selbst erst einmal selbst an was
könnte der grund sein
was könnte der grund dafür sein dass
kann sagt wir können blödsinn maxime
wieder landen erkennen dieser grund ist
relativ einsichtig dass wir die erste
frau die zweite warum kann man es nicht
mehr wo uns selbst einziehen was wie
eine grund dafür dass kann sagt wir
können es nicht bei jemandem anderen
erkennen die maxi
hier können
kunst entscheiden
genau wir können ja nicht in seinen kopf
reinschauen
er trägt die maxime ja nicht auf der
piste auf der stirn oder wo auch sonst
gut manche haben hier so ein motto sein
lebensmotto roten t shirt aber das kann
ja auch nur fake sein und dazu kommt
noch der zweite punkt die person selbst
weiß ja selbst nicht ob sie jetzt eine
böse maxime angewendet hatte nicht die
zweite frage warum nicht
er war
ja das wäre eine möglichkeit dass wir in
so ein regress kommen man kann immer
weiter fragen wie warum hast du diese
maxime gewählt
also warum hast du diese handlung getan
warum weil ich diese maxime hatte warum
haben hattest du diese maxime ja weil
ich die von einem noch höheren maxime
von einer noch allgemeineren stufe der
maxime ausgewählt haben warum hast du
diese maxime it-welt der weil ich noch
wochen noch einen grund hat immer weiter
zu führen
den ersten grund kann man es an geben
das wäre eine möglichkeit haben sie noch
eine andere möglichkeit warum man es
nicht wissen kann ja ganz genau das ist
auch noch ein sehr guter punkt kant ist
so ein kritischer menschenkenner kate
ist selbstprüfung protest feindlichen
sind dass er die menschen so traut sich
selbst zu belügen
der mensch macht sich etwas vor der
mensch ist nicht so ehrlich dass es sagt
hier habe ich jetzt diese maxime zu
einem menschen der täuscht sich
permanent auch über das was ihn selbst
vorgehe
ich glaube ein ganz wichtiger punkt auch
das verkehrsproblem und wir haben das
selbst bewegungs problem selbst täuschen
es sind zwar ganz wichtige faktoren da
ist kann sehr realistisch für dich und
ich glaube durchaus dass der
protestantisch geschult ist in dieser
dieser seelen prüfung dieser
selbstprüfung na das ist ja
nur protestantischer topos gibt es dabei
luther was wo man bei luther findet dass
das man sich selbst prüfen soll das ist
diese pietistische selbstprüfung er
später dann bei
sola fide gelten ständigen zweifel
richtig nur das praktische seite wollen
wir den menschen mit tieren das ist ja
genau dies ab
mal an sich selbst zweifeln mensch weil
er nicht weiß welche maxime über dir
nicht verfügen kann ihn richtig und das
ist noch ein guter punkt nämlich heißt
nicht was hier aber sogar also ich hab
fast dafür verurteilt stehen
verwerfliche tat gewesen und man sagt ja
ich weiß nicht was mich geritten hat als
ich das gemacht habe
im sinne von ich weiß gar nicht welche
maxi
das war die nicht davon haben tun lassen
also dieses gefühl einer virtuellen
fremdbestimmung durch maxim mit dem man
nicht verfügen haben
das ist glaube ich ging es dann auch in
diese richtung sola fide also nur durch
glaube als nicht durch werke
letztendlich auch also werke wäre die
verfügbarkeit an der maxime versuchen
das ganze ins positive
also ich möchte auch durch
maxi ist der zweite gleich in zwei wilde
welt sagen dass das was ich gutes zu
überhaupt wirklich gutes mich nicht in
wirklichkeit eigentlich wieder von dem
entfernt was ich denke es ist sehr unter
der funktion neben 2
an der eigenen leistungsfähigkeit
es erkennt beurteilt geschweige denn zu
tun
noch lägen zwar dass es könnte er
dadurch etwas ausrichten blick auf seine
halt sein hier
das wäre dann dieses noch größere
setting dieses er theologie und
theologische oder auch postleb zwischen
settings täglich also frag einen
rechtfertigen
sonst ist es mädchen gekommen ist und
überhaupt das rechtfertigen ein problem
ist ja bekannt
grundsätzlich habe neue füße gestellt
deswegen dieses attestiert nie ein haus
biete
also mit einem worte bekannt ist bella
diana könnte man das sagen also jetzt
nach luther oder in diesem schema also
einige sagen das ist kein plagiat was
war nochmal belgien kurz wissen sie es
noch denken sie noch mal die übersicht
der wiedergegeben hat man diese
verschiedenen abzweigung ja
selten
genau die wendung zum guten haben wir in
unserer kraft
ich denke kann gegen die tendenz eines
plagiats natürlich würde er das nicht so
theologisch gewendet sagen er würde nie
sagen wir haben die freiheit zum guten
angesichts gottes einem 18er würde die
theologische dimension ausblenden und
sagen ich rede jetzt hier nur das
moralische und auch da würde er es sagen
was ihnen da wieder so ein bisschen
absprechen würde gerne wie kann es
eigentlich gar nicht sicher wissen so
richtig da kommt dann doch ein stärker
lutherische gedanke rein
es würde doch dann diesen vorwurf des
plagiats muss an kant etwas relativieren
oder die frage ist nur der ton warum er
jetzt die einsicht in das gut sein
system ist relativiert ich glaube eben
nicht dass diese systemische
relativierung der erkenntnis des guten
und bösen biologische gründe bekannt
dass es sagen würde
weil wenn wir es erkennen würden dann
würden wir uns zum gott machen wir
wüssten was gut und böse ist
ich glaube nicht dass das sehr
theologische gründe sind sondern einfach
ästhetische gründe vielleicht auch so
ein pessimismus ein bisschen kann man
sich fragen aber letztendlich denkt sind
die flucht perspektiven dieselben dann
diese epische einschränkung dies in
letzter hinsicht doch auf die
endlichkeit des menschen bezogen und
auch
die lutherische sicht natürlich auch der
mensch ist ein ähnliches wesen und
sollte nicht versuchen sich zum gott zu
machen wieder mehr kennen warum handeln
[Musik]
der des sogenannten deutschen
protestantismus also deren innovative
und das tat irgendwie der letzten 150
jahren hat genau diese nicht versucht zu
leisten nämlich die verbindung gehabt
es war alles kann gläser hand ferreira
verhandlungen mit dem
neu kann ich das muss natürlich
verwandte theologen die zugleich eine
mutter gelesen haben sich eine neue
mutter ausgaben unter erstmal da als
nicht eines kindes konzessions gründen
gesehen haben sondern überall
einen technologischen schritt schneller
war
die lesen haben festgestellt dass es da
gewisse sachen gibt eine art moderne
gegen die mutter habe ich zu erzeugen
dass er durch den kampf hindurch
diese kann dafür genannt ist es ganz
toll dass man auch über 200 m
protestantismus und wahrscheinlich zu
kommen
vor genau in dieser verbindung weil es
schon wieder so eine art ja auch
letztlich den theologisch gebildeter bis
zum kritischen und liege
könnte man auch so ein bisschen als eine
art optimismus stoll hatte nämlich sehr
genau es gibt sehr viele eigene meistens
fähigkeiten des menschen sein die in der
kritik sich dann sozusagen verschärft
aktualisiert bei gleichzeitiger
abschluss und wieso also auch selber
physischen theoretischen fragen die
dabei eine rolle spielen meinte man eben
mit unseren asse zu selten mit cantus
war dementsprechend einer modernen gegen
das ist unglaublich
haben
es bleiben beim aktivist des
mittelstandes nicht sozusagen der
austrianer was man sich das vor allem
aus katholischer sicht gedacht sondern
kann es vielmehr ein
die ganze kraft ging es zurück zum wagen
und damit eigentlich auch dieses mal
vorgeführt und zu beseitigen und der
herzen furchtbaren metaphysik des
mittelalters
doch wird dieser ganzen käse der
funktionelle war sie haben das
christentum angedockt hat eine kritische
philosophie des crea kritische theologie
des zorns künftig eine kritik des
christentums nicht eine kritik der
reinen vernunft
die politische arbeit als
protestantischer verstanden und den
kampf dafür sein
naja ob das ist natürlich eine
angemessene und er ist eine ganz andere
frage aber es spricht einiges dafür und
es war
die sagen schon brisant weil zudem
sehr selektiven gelehrten waren sollen
die affen die eigentlich und ich kann
auch dann ganz gelesen haben und ganz
ja also vielen dank sie sehen man kann
also doch die ganzen denker die wir
bisher behandelt hatten wir bekommen
noch mit einer denkerin hannah arendt
aber bisher nur mit männlichen wesen die
kann man alles sehr sehr gut in einem
verhältnis setzen wir hatten den
augustinus der spielt immer eine rolle
der kommt bei ihr richtig hingewiesen
wurde der kommt bei leibnitz vor wir
hatten es mit luther zu tun der immer
eine rolle spielt also man kann hier
alle denker sehr schön miteinander in
ein verhältnis lassen jetzt geht es
weiter
jetzt
spricht er hiervon
dem ablesen dass hier das heute noch
sagen na wir lesen doch mal dass hier
weiter also es geht jetzt um die frage
ob der mensch eine böse natur hat kann
spricht von einer fahrt von bösen natur
das ist eine frage immer da zu verstehen
hat damit man sich aber nicht sofort am
ausdrucke der natur stoße welcher wenn
er wie gewöhnlich das gegenteil des
grundes der handlung aus freiheit
bedeuten sollte mit dem prädikat
moralisch guten bösen gerade widerspruch
stehen würde es merken dass hier unter
der natur des menschen nur der
subjektive grund des gebrauch seiner
freiheit überhaupt und objektiven
moralischen gesetzen der vor allem aller
in die sinne fallenden tat vorher geht
verstanden werde
dieser grund marken und liegen worin er
wolle also kann spricht von natur des
menschen in zwei verschiedenen hinsicht
heimat spricht er so von der natur des
menschen dass darin seine natürliche
determination bestehen und dann ist die
natur des menschen das wenige wasser mit
freiheit beschränkt das ist eine
redeweise von natur natur aber auch so
verstehen und das ist jetzt hier in
diesem zitat gemeint dass darin
letztendlich seine freiheit natur
besteht den grund seiner freiheit
und in diesem sinne wäre jetzt natur wie
er sagt der subjektive gibt grund des
gebrauchs seiner freiheit also der der
urgrund sozusagen die wurzel könnte man
auch sagen um so in dieser
metaphorischen jetzt sagt er diese
urgrund des bösen oder auch des guten
was auch immer der freiheit der besteht
in einer vor allem die sinne fallenden
tat
weiß jemand wie man diese tat bekannt
wie kann diese tat nimmt diese vor allem
in die sinne fallenden tat die vor allem
die sinne fallenden dinge sich vollzieht
es ist nicht so wichtig kann dass die
intelligent ein intelligenter hat kann
sagt also das böse das ist eine ganz
spannende sache
das böse ist jetzt nichts was aus
unserer natur folgt das ist nochmal ganz
wichtig das böse folgt nicht aufgrund
unserer natürlichen begrenzung oder wohl
unserer trieben
das ist wieder so ein bisschen was
leibnitz janisch es fällt mir grad ein
das böse hat was mit unserer
intelligenten natur zu tun und liebt die
natur das wäre dann wieder so ein
bisschen an eine mahnung mit der physik
kommt man jetzt erstmals in das böse
oder auch das gute besteht in der wurzel
unserer freiheit und die wurzel unserer
freiheit nennt kann jetzt natur aber
nicht im sinne der natur im eigentlichen
sinne sind der empirischen bedingtheit
determination redet der hmi nationen zur
natur in diesem sinne dass damit der
urgrund unserer freiheit bezeichnet ist
und diese uhr grund ist ein
intelligenter hat was mit unserer
vernunft tun müssen wir weiter lesen
so ist zu merken dass hier unter natur
des menschen nur das subjektive gebrauch
seiner freiheit überhaupt unter
objektiven iranischen gesetzen das haben
schon gehabt er vor aller in diesem fall
einen tag vorher geht verstanden werde
diese grund marken und liegen wo genannt
wurde dieser subjektive grund muss aber
wiederum selbst ein akt der freiheit
sein denn sonst könnte der gebrauch der
missbrauch der willkür des menschen in
anziehung des sittlichen gesetzes die
nicht zugerechnet werden und das gute
oder böse in ihm nicht moralisch heiß
mädchen kann in keinem der willkür durch
neigung bestimmenden objekte in calais
natur triebe ist nur in einer regel die
die willkür sich selbst für den gebrauch
ihrer freiheit macht das heißt einer
maxime der kunden liegen
er kommt jetzt wieder wird andere
argumentationsweise kommt er jetzt hier
wieder zu dem ergebnis dass das
eigentlich böse mensch handlung ist
uneben maxime sind subjektiven quatsch
warum begründet dass jetzt damit dass
die maxime eben nichts ist was die natur
der termination unterliegt das meinte
damit dass er sagt durch keine durch
neigung bestimmte objekte keine betriebe
unterliegt
keine toten das böse ist nicht nur sache
des natur trebs lust unlust hunger was
nicht das böse besteht darin dass wir
eine maxime aus freiheit angenommen
haben
die dazu geführt hat
also wir haben es gewählt mir wurden
dazu nicht gezwungen durch natur
instinkt natur trieb ist eine in der tat
und energieplanung ich kann man sich
immer noch fragen ja wie sie zu einer
intelligenten tat aus und worin liegt
jetzt genau der erste grund und jetzt
sagt er folgendes dazu
von dieser also von dieser maxime von
dieser muss nun nicht weiter gefragt
werden können was der subjektive grund
ihrer annehmen und nicht vielmehr der
entgegengesetzten maxime im menschen
zeit denn wenn dieser grund zur jetzt
selbst keine maxime mehr zum bloßen
betrieb wäre so wird der gebrauch der
freiheit ganz auf bestimmung durch natur
ursachen zurückgeführt werden können
welches team ja aber widerspricht wenn
wir also sagen der mensch ist von natur
aus gut oder des senators böse so
bedeutet dies nur nun so viel als er
enthält ein uns ohne erforderlichen mit
systemischer einschränken ersten grund
der annehmen guter oder der anime böser
gesetz integra max 7 und zwar alle
gemein als mensch mit hinzu diese durch
dieselbe zugleich den charakter seiner
gattung ausdrückt jetzt kommt doch was
weiteres ins spiel
jetzt erkannt also es ist fast ein jahr
denkt notwendigkeit die tatsache dass
der mensch frei ist dass er einmal was
böses getan hat der böse handlung
vollzogen hat folgen daraus
notwendigerweise dass wir davon ausgehen
müssen dass eine uhr maxime gewählt
wurde ein erster grund weil wenn es
nicht sein erster grund wäre die
intelligente gewählt wäre dann würde nur
übrig bleiben dass der erste grund in
der natur trieben blicks und das
wiederum würde uns die freiheit nehmen
wenn der erste grund der annäherung
böser max 7 in einem triebwagen etwas
natürlich im blick dann sind wir darin
nach kant hätten bestimmt wird uns aber
das böse nicht mehr richtig zu rechnen
dass sein
es muss also das sei jedenfalls begriffe
ich folgte das daraus und jetzt sagt er
noch was ganz am ende dieses zitates der
menschen zeigt sich in dem er böses tut
oder auch gutes tut nicht als ein
individuum so er zeigt sich als
repräsentant seiner gattung
als er drückt den charakter seiner
gattung aus als es geht hier um und das
ist diese doppeldeutigkeit von natur des
bösen
es ist einmal der intelligenz des bösen
die wurzel und einmal seine natur als
mensch hat es ist halt die menschliche
natur so ist der mensch hat also will
kann sagen jeder vans mensch als mensch
und nicht nur ein besonderes individuums
und der mensch als mensch hat irgendwann
diese größe maxime gewählt diesen
urkunden und zwar nicht aus natur
trieben herauslöst freie entscheidung
und das sind kann dann in theley tag
werden dann noch ein bisschen näher
darauf zurückkommen und jetzt sagte
folgendes dass wir aber unter den
menschen von denen wir sagen es sei von
natur gut oder böse nicht den einzelnen
verstehen da als dann einer von natur
gut der andere als böse angenommen
werden könnte sondern die ganze gattung
zu verstehen
im fokus sind wir sind also berechtigt
das zu tun kann nur weiterhin bewiesen
werden wenn es sich in der
anthropologischen nach forschung zeigt
dass die gründe die uns berechtigen
menschen ein von beiden charakteren als
angeboren beizulegen so beschaffen sind
das kein grund ist ein menschen davon
auszunehmen
und er also von der gattung geld her
okay jetzt sagt er hier selbst dass man
das durch anthropologischen
nachforschung zeigen müsse tja das ist
ein bisschen die spannung weil
anthropologischen nachforschung ja hier
auf der ebene der handlung sich
vollzieht und auf der ebene des menschen
und letztendlich mit maxxim gar nichts
mehr zu tun haben
was könnte damit gemeinsam mit
anthropologische nachforschen
[Musik]
was ist anthropologie
die könnte man jetzt ein
forschungsprogramm konzipieren um zu
zeigen oder zumindest plausibel zu
machen dass wir keinen menschen davon
ausnehmen können von dieser böse natur
sie könnte man ein solches
anthropologisches forschungsprogramm
design
anthropologie ist die lehre des menschen
also müsst ihr einfach schauen in die
welt gehen zeigen dass in allen kulturen
der mensch irgendwie böses tut
zu allen zeiten wie überall und ich
glaube die geschichte zeigt schon das
alte rom beim griechen war richtig groß
so zb tendenziell so ein bisschen gesagt
das böse kommt erst der im gesellschaft
und spiel in unsere vernunft sich
entwickelt und dann anfängt zu
vergleichen und dann kommen durch den
vergleich der vernunft solche bösen
einstellungen die welt wie neid habgier
eifersucht und so ein zufall
richtig
für diese nicht den abgewehrten ball
agiert hat hat die qual
burda ist
auf der anderen seite gibt es bei keinem
leben wieder diese these dass er sagt
der kategorische imperativ ist jedem
vernunft wesen und dann sagt auch jedem
menschen prinzipiell zu gehen das beißt
sich bei kann bisschen aber ist ein
richtiger hinweis dass bei kann
problematisch empirische äußerungen
darüber zu finden sind
das war da noch einen helden
weiter
heller
richtig sie frage also muss nicht
notwendigerweise mit dem individuum in
zusammenhängen
ja
bruder punkt guter punkt ist dass der
termin ist muss werden es betrifft
dieselbe frage wie bei leibnitz durch
das manometer physikum sind wieder alle
mit determiniert zum bösen deswegen
müssen wir weiter lesen weil jetzt hier
verschiedene anlagen unterscheiden in
der menschlichen natur in booten also
sowie zu ihrer frage noch kann sagt wir
haben einen hang zum bösen in unsere
mensch natur und eine anlage zum gut
auch in unserer natur
man sagt wir haben beides wir sind nicht
nur in der natur irgendwie determiniert
sind wir aber auch in der anlage zum
guten dann kann man sich wieder fallen
ja woher kommt dann die entscheidung für
das ein oder andere in der erste grund
doch irgendwie in der gattung
aber er sagt auch eine anlage zum also
nicht nur das böse jetzt von dieser
ursprüngliche anklage ursprünglich main
in der gattung also ganz basal ganz
unten von der ursprünglichen anlage zum
kunden der menschennatur sagte wir
können sie in beziehungen auf den zweck
wirklich auf
drei klassen als er hinter der
bestimmung des menschen bringen die
anlage für die tierhalter des menschen
eines lebenden das also für ihn gut
gut ist dass wir leben zweitens für die
menschheit desselben als eines lebenden
und zugleich vernünftigen das ist
verkannt aber jetzt noch nicht die
entscheidung für des menschen vielen
anthropologen oder viele philosophen
würden sagen damit haben wir den
menschen bestimmt als menschen wenn wir
sagen er ist lebendig und ist wichtig
zum beispiel die aristotelische
definition sagt ante post zurück und ich
kann also ein lebewesen was vernunft hat
die aristotelische definition mensch
gleich natur oder leben plus vernunft
neins erkannt es gibt eine dritte stufe
für seine persönlichkeit als eines
vernünftig und zugleich der
zurechnungsfähigen wesen also die
höchste stufe der anlage zum guten ist
die persönlichkeit die nicht nur
vernünftig und lebendig ist sondern
moralisch verantwortlich ist die
moralisch zur verantwortung gezogen
werden
frage
hat man diese persönlichkeit oder diese
zurechenbarkeit nicht auch schon in
punkt 2 erreicht wenn es hier darum
gehen dass hier jemand vernünftig ist ja
das ist die frage
kann man diesen diskussionen jetzt daran
anknüpfen ich geb dir noch ein seminar
über den geist der tiere und man könnte
jetzt so kann verteidigen uns sagen ja
gut rationalität setzt nicht moralische
zurechenbarkeit voraus rationalität
bedeutet noch nicht geübt so die
entwicklung von moralität zb sehr
intelligente tiere wie krähen und raben
die haben sicherlich vernunft oder
rationalität jetzt im weitesten sinne
weil sie instrumentelle vernunft haben
sie schaffen es werkzeuge herzustellen
das hat man gezeigt dass raben krähen
sich kleine trat konstruktion bauen um
damit an futter zu kommen wo sie sonst
mit ihrem schmalen hin kernfrage ist
dann damit schon einhergehend das graben
moralisch verantwortlich sind
offensichtlich nein also erscheint jetzt
sehr weiten begriff von 5 zu haben es
satt als es muss noch was dazukommen
und es ist die zurechenbarkeit und das
macht dann ist seine persönlichkeit geht
verhält und sagt das ist jetzt so ein
bisschen
jetzt hat er nämlich auch noch im
gegenteil
parallel dazu diese auflistung dieser
dieser bösen also jetzt nicht mehr hier
die ursprüngliche anlage zum guten
seinen hang zum bösen jetzt sagt er hier
die anlage für die tierhaltung menschen
kann man unter den allgemein titel der
physischen und bloß mechanischen
selbstliebe das ist einer solchen
bringen wozu nicht vernunft erforderlich
ist sie ist rechtlich so erhaltung
seiner selbst zwei zur fortpflanzung
seiner art durch die trieb zum
geschlecht und zur erhaltung dessen was
durch vermischung mit demselben erzeugt
drittens zur gemeinschaft mit anderen
menschen das ist der trieb zur
gesellschaft auf sie können allerlei
laster getropft werden aber nicht aus
jener anlage als wurzel von selbst
erschließen
sie können lastete ruhig kite der natur
heißen und werden in ihrer höchsten
abweichen von natur zwecke vier laster
der völlerei da mal die trägheit oder
der wollust der wilden gesetzlosigkeit
im verhältnis zu anderen menschen
genannt
und jetzt sagt da gibt es hier in der
anlage zur menschheit auch wieder was
böses er sagte weiter unten gibt es hier
so was was die menschheit übersteigt im
night in der undankbarkeit die der
schadenfreude und sogar in den
teuflischen lastern und jetzt wollen wir
noch einmal ganz kurz hier auf den hang
zum bösen menschen natur kommen bevor
das seminar zu ende ist oder eine
pension verstehe ich den subjektiven
grund für möglichkeit einer neigung
sofern sie für die menschheit überhaupt
zufällig ist und das ist für auf ihre
frage er sagt es liegt in der menschheit
der hang zum bösen aber zufällig also
nicht notwendig was heißt das jetzt
genau das ist wie bei leibnitz das
manometer physikum führt
notwendigerweise zur möglichkeit des
moran speisen und das physisch
physischen und jetzt aber nicht eben
notwendig er unterscheidet sich darin
von einer anlage dass er zwar angeboren
sein kann aber doch nicht als solcher
vorgestellt werden darf sagt auch wenn
er gut ist als erworben oder wenn er
böse ist als von den menschen selbst
sich zugezogen gedacht werden kann
also muss dann wieder aus freiheit also
es muss ein hang sein der aus freiheit
zu gezogen worden
das ist aber hier nur vom hang zum
eigentlich das halt so moralisch bösen
die rede welches da es nur als
bestimmung der freiwillig möglich ist
diese aber als gut böse nur durch ihre
maxime beurteilt werden kann
an dem subjektiven krüger möglichkeit
der abweichung der maxime von
moralischen gesetze bestehen muss und
wenn dieser hang als allgemein zum
menschen als als zum charakter seiner
gattung gehörig angenommen werden darf
ein natürlicher hang des menschen zum
bösen genannt
werden wird man kann auch hin zu setzen
dass die aus dem natürlichen hgn
springen die fähigkeit oder unfähigkeit
der willkür das moralische gesetz in
seine maxime aufzunehmen oder nicht das
gute oder böse herz genannt werden
deshalb folgendes es ist ganz schwierig
vorzustellen sagt der hang ist zufällig
für die gattung und er ist selbst
zugezogen
ganz seltsam also der hang zum bösen
liegt irgendwie der natuerlichen unserer
sinnlichkeit mit unseren natürlichen
determination sonst der freiheit erlebt
zugleich nicht in uns als individuum
sondern in uns als gattung und
musterfälle darin liegt als selbst
zugezogen gedacht wird als die freiheit
kommt immer wieder rein
ganz schwierig wie man das aufklären
möchte und jetzt zum schluss noch
folgendes zitat man kann sich drei
verschiedene stufen des selben also des
hangs zu lösen denken
letztlich ist es die schwäche des
menschlichen herzens in bevölkerung
angenommen maxim überhaupt ohne die
gebrechlichkeit der menschlichen natur
zweitens der hand vermischung
moralischer triebfedern für den
moralischen selbst wenn es um gute
absichten unter maxime des guten
geschehen dh die unlauterkeit tretens
und jetzt kommt die hand zu nehmen böser
maxime
das ist die bösartigkeit der
menschlichen natur des menschen erkennt
hier verschiedene stufen des bösen
das ist allemal eine stärke von kants
türken
ich denke bis dahin können wir uns mal
belassen lesen sie hier
die zitate noch ein bisschen weiter und
vor allem mit blick auf dieses zitat
seite 34 35 worin der grund des bösen
jetzt wirklich besteht besteht er in der
sinnlichkeit des menschen haben wir
schon gesagt in der natur als empirische
natur kann es irgendwie nicht bestehen
das wäre ja nicht freien das wäre nicht
zu rechnen war
und jetzt kann man sich zweitens fragen
kann dann das böse nicht im gegenteil
zur natur in der vernunft bestehen in
unserer nationalität sondern auch das
erkannt darin kann es auch nicht
bestehen und jetzt wollen wir in der
nächsten sitzung fragen ja worin besteht
dann der grund des bösen wenn er nicht
in unser sind natur besteht noch in
unserer von brindl schildert dann das
wollen wir uns noch ein bisschen
überlegen
wir werden den nächsten sitzung also
nochmal auf kann kurz zurück kommen und
werden dann aber uns mit schelling
beschäftigen mit seiner freiheit stirbt
und schauen wie schelling an kant
angriff wo inwiefern der bösen eine ganz
neue werden und gibt falls schelling in
der regel als zäsur gilt in der debatte
um das böse dann bis zum nächsten
sitzung